joining us now for reaction in New York
is monica crowley she's a senior fellow
at the London Center for Policy Research
and here in Washington Tamar Jacoby
she's an immigration activist and
president and CEO of immigration works
and corey lewandowski
former campaign manager for donald trump
and co-author of the new bestseller let
Trump beat Trump all right Cory um there
are people you heard my radio listeners
they are really worried I want to hold
out hope and reserve judgment for the
final deal but you heard this the quotes
from the president at that meeting he
will agree to anything they say it the
deal is going to get done comprehensive
immigration reform is coming and just
that alone and then of course throw in
the reference to the hard right and
people aren't too happy the ones who
actually stood in line and the heat in
the winter weather to see him this
president has made campaign promises
that he needs to fulfill and if you
don't fulfill those campaign promises
what we will see in November is a
retaliation against the president
because he hasn't done that and the
first and biggest campaign promise that
he made was to build a wall I went to
all those rallies we heard the response
we saw that Mexico we heard that Mexico
was going to pay for it this is a
hallmark of the campaign that Donald
Trump ran on to make sure that we're
putting America first that has been his
agenda that is what he campaigned on and
that's what's going to fulfill as the
president noted States tomorrow the
people like Jeff Flake who didn't even
vote for the president he's probably in
closer to you and agreement on
immigration than he certainly is someone
like me or the candidate Trump he said
the the wall will be something like
maybe 700 miles but it won't really be a
wall everywhere it'll be kind of fencing
and so forth would that be acceptable to
someone like you
no I think we need to secure the border
we need to do whatever it takes to
secure the border and there's a Jeff
Flake is not the only person in Congress
who's working on this and he's not the
only person who said the president was
going in the right direction today so
did John Cornyn and some conservative
senators like Tillis and Lankford and
people and I have people in the house
like good lad and Labrador there are
plenty of conservative to hardline
republicans who will think we need a doc
a deal and think a doc a deal
the way to build the wall guess of
course we stand on the wall I mean I
think you're right there's not the votes
to do that but obviously you could
physically you could be but I want to
find the money the way to get the money
out of Congress some bipartisan vote but
if if people actually thought that a
fortified border was important and you
we need roads there we need a wall or
sectors we need judges we so that is a
absolute must to have so why link it to
the daca amnesty at all what are the
daca amnesty have to do with the
fortifying army since the beginning
since before he was inaugurated that he
thought that we should do something for
the daca kids well so do you link it why
don't you never to be linked well why
not have some democrat boats and do it
in a bipartisan way what's so Robbie's
bipartisanship bad by the Democrats are
for enforcement you just said I mean
you're for enforcement I'm you're not a
conservative Republican Democrats are
really a Republican I'm not a Democrat
okay so Chuck Schumer has said many
times he's for enforcement other
Democrats they're totally for
enforcement but they also want to do
something for the daca kids right as
does the president Monica look I want to
believe in my heart of hearts that there
is not some major sellout in the offing
I can't imagine the president would do
that I mean that would be the end of his
presidency he wouldn't I think you know
look you already have people who are
concerned about this but it goes ahead
and does that you know I think that few
people have given him better advice and
probably you know the kids sitting kids
he's a kid to me Cory sitting here
myself and a few others but he has a lot
of friends now newfound friends who were
calling him racist sexist xenophobic
seems like yesterday yeah I don't think
he cares much about his newfound friends
who are lavishing him with praise based
on on what went down in that meeting
yesterday Laura look we are a little
worried because we're so conditioned by
establishment Republicans and others who
have led us down over many decades
people on both sides of the aisle
frankly this president is completely
different I think what you saw in that
meeting
Donald Trump knew what he was doing he
knew what he was doing without strategic
contradiction look he of all of his
campaign promises build the wall
inspired the most
support I don't think he's gonna let us
down on that his platform about dealing
with illegal immigration once and for
all he knows he's got one shot before
the end of the year in the 2018 midterm
elections he knows what he's got to do
he's got to start funding building the
wall he's got to end sanctuary cities
he's got to end the visa lottery program
he's done tuition GreenHeart card called
Isis absolutely he's got to accelerate
deportations and he's got to unblock
those immigration courts I know that's a
tall order Laura but this president is
up to it that's what he promised he's
not a difference promises got to do it
he can't be whatever Durbin and
Feinstein and Cory Gardner agreed to I
have court eager I've thoughts for Cory
Gardner later on in the show people do
not want to miss what I'm about to
reveal about Cory Gardner Lindsey Graham
said this today to any of us who would
dare criticize these tactics let's watch
those folks don't have to solve problems
the President does he's got to work for
with Democrats to fix problems like
immigration they don't they're pretty
much outliers when it comes to where the
American people are his job is not to
sell books his job is not to carry a TV
show his job is to solve problems
oh thanks Lindsey that was we didn't
realize that he's actually the president
Cory take a shot at that one look the
president has been brought to Washington
to solve the problems at this Congress
and many before them have created the
last fix the problems they haven't done
so Donald Trump has now come in passed a
massive tax reform package the first
time since the Reagan administration
celebrate and what what the president's
going to do is to fulfill the campaign
promises that he outlined what we saw
yes a was quintessential Donald Trump he
brought the cameras I love to hold those
I love how those guys accountable I love
it you do more of it have them
accountable on television great the
Democrats hate that because they want to
go and make this rhetoric and have these
propaganda Lindsey Graham to be sitting
at that table you know your friends
stick up for your friends when Lindsey
Graham sitting up at the table and I
like him personally very much always up
Fox News and hard right he tried this
line in 2007 he went down in flames in
2007 they tried it in 2014
you know who's no longer
here in Washington John Boehner and Eric
Cantor you know why they're not here
because they sold the country out
primarily on immigration tomorrow I want
to go with you on this on the issue of
chain migration the Democrats have said
I've been able to interview they are not
for reductions to chain migration what
is your sense all the time over time we
definitely need to rebalance too much as
family migration not enough is
employment-based migration but it's a
really it's a it's a that's a historic
change we're gonna change 200 years of
history we need to do it carefully
and Democrats aren't going to be ready
to do it it's right now across the board
and this deal will make something can
they I mean I think it's possible to
make some changes to chain migration
right but to totally change the system I
don't think it's going to happen sorry
this is a record we actually changed our
immigration policy in 1965 changing it
from a merit-based system to primarily a
bringing in the entire family tree
migration we had heavy and it was a
country based and people brought behind
they knew from their listeners
understand what we're talking about here
there are a million green card grants
every day granted every we're and 44
percent our family migration there are
other family recipients that come in
only 18 percent are jobs related
immigration eight the families work to
the families work second cousin twice
removed the children that my uncle 99.9%
of the facilities work and they and
families are doomed
Republicans believe in pitches labor
businesses families creates a certain
social fabric social like American
families aren't the social fabric we got
a lot of families sing a bunch of straw
man workers and not them families so
they're better than we are
no there's no illegals coming in with
all the extent ideally are better than
the American workers no I think their
family no I didn't say anything like
that immigration I think immigration
should be legal not illegal but some
family migration is not a bad thing
adults
spouses and children yeah illegal people
Donald Trump said countless times on the
campaign trail need to go home and apply
the right way that's the rule of law if
you want to change the law change it but
I'm telling you something compromise on
this thing is this gonna be a bridge too
far all of you we can have you for an
hour I wish we did